hey david what happened to defund the
police
did they do it and why isn't anyone
talking about it anymore
yeah i don't know if the question is
being asked cynically or sarcastically
or rhetorically
so a bunch of different things happened
first of all um
society has just sort of moved on in
some sense
and i don't mean all together from
defund the police there's still a
ton of activism going on but it's not
the lead story
on cnn msnbc and fox every single day
it's not making headlines
in the world's most read the country's
most read newspaper so
in a sense it the topic of defund the
police has simmered down now you all
know i was never for defund the police i
was
for how would i say it i was for
fund more crime prevention and better
train
police by providing the appropriate
resources
for the policing situation as judged on
an individual basis
that's a terrible tagline i'm not a
marketing guy i admit that
um but for me the idea of
uh eliminating or defunding police never
made sense i laid out
all the reasons why it and and absent
some real way to prevent crime um
defunding police i just don't think
is uh something that that was ever going
to really catch on now what i do think
is
typically police are responding to crime
so sure investigative new
units joint terrorism task force fbi
cia dea you know you've all these
different entities and many of them are
working on
preventing major crimes from happening
in advance
police mostly are responding to crimes
and are not
nearly as often in a situation where
they can prevent one sometimes
police interfere in or interject into a
situation
where a crime has been committed and
they prevent further crime so in a
shooting
where two people have been killed police
show up maybe nobody else gets killed
which could happen if the shooter is
just left alone but for the most part
police are not really day-to-day street
police are not preventing
crime in the way that maybe we would
like to see happen
um access to social workers and mental
health services
prevents crime food stamps and anything
that makes people
uh you know to be in a less desperate
situation where there might they might
feel
uh compelled to commit a crime to feed
their family or themselves
that prevents crime good schools prevent
prime uh prevent crime
good public transit so people can get to
where the jobs are
that prevents crime uh affordable sports
and you know the way that we prevent
crime
has less to do with police themselves
with all of the exceptions that i listed
so i think that the focus
should really be let's fund crime
prevention
and reform the police with the 10 to 12
bullet point
outline that i've given in the past um
in terms of just the the dialogue around
defund
there are cities that recently have been
seeing more violence
not because they defunded now this is
really important you
see some republicans don jr will do this
he'll say look at what defund the police
brought to this city and then you look
and it's like yeah
they had to defund the police protest
but the police weren't defunded
you can't blame defunding the police for
crime when the police were not defunded
i do think that more visible crime in
some cities over the last six months
has probably a little bit taken the wind
out of the sales
of the straight-up defund movement it
should do nothing
at all to take our minds off of the
fund crime prevention and reform the
police movement
that's where i've been for years on this
issue
and i see more of my audience coming
around to it and i think that that's a
very good thing
let me know what you think and we have a
fantastic bonus show planned for you
today
join pacman.com and sign up to get
instant access to today's bonus show we
will see you then one of our sponsors is
vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one watch that makes you
feel great when you put it on you can
often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy
and five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman